que fueran comestibles?
¿Qué pasaría si pudiéramos cambiar completamente la experiencia,
como ven con la funda de absenta
que está totalmente impresa en 3D?
Y ¿qué pasa si pudiéramos empezar a añadir ingredientes
y colores y sabores de todos los gustos,
que no solamente significara comida deliciosa
sino la promesa de una nutrición personalizada
a la vuelta de la esquina?
Y eso me lleva a una de las cosas más grandes sobre la impresión 3D.
Con la impresión 3D, la complejidad es gratuita.
A la impresora le da igual
si crea la forma más rudimentaria
o la forma más compleja,
y eso está volcando completamente
el diseño y la fabricación como los conocemos.
Muchos piensan que la impresión 3D será
el fin de la fabricación como la conocemos.
Yo pienso que es la oportunidad de poner
la tecnología del futuro en las manos de los jóvenes
que crearán abundancia sin fin
de oportunidades de empleo,
y con eso,
todos pueden convertirse en creadores expertos
y fabricantes expertos.
Eso precisará nuevas herramientas.
No todos saben utilizar CAD,
y estamos desarrollando dispositivos
hápticos de percepción
que permitirán tocar
y sentir los diseños
como si se jugara con arcilla digital.
Al hacer cosas como esas,
y también desarrollar cosas que toman
fotografías físicas que son imprimibles al instante,
se facilita la creación del contenido,
pero con todo lo inimaginado,
también tendremos falsificación
democratizada no intencional
y posesión ilegal ubicua.
Mucha gente me pregunta,
si tendremos una impresora 3D en todos los hogares.
Pienso que la pregunta no es correcta.
La pregunta correcta que hay que hacerse es,
¿cómo la impresión 3D cambiará mi vida?
En otras palabras, ¿en qué habitación de mi casa
encajará la impresión 3D?
Y todo lo que ven aquí
fue impreso en 3D,
incluyendo estos zapatos
en la feria de la moda de Ámsterdam.
Bien, no son los zapatos de mi abuelo.
Esos zapatos representan
la continuación de su pasión
por la fabricación hiperlocal.
Mi abuelo no llegó a conocer
los tacos impresos de Nike para el último Super Bowl
Y mi padre no llegó a verme usando
mis zapatos hibridados impresos en 3D.
Él falleció hace tres años.
Pero Chuck Hull, el hombre que lo inventó todo,
está aquí mismo en el salón,
y gracias a él,
puedo decir, gracias a su invención, puedo decir
que soy también zapatero,
Y al usar estos zapatos
estoy honrando mi pasado
mientras fabrico mi futuro.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)